hi guys I'm Greg I'm Greg - we're going
to be doing a review for the film a cure
for wellness normally we have a green
screen that has a picture of it the
movie to enhance the experience sitting
here we'll do well John's green hair
kind of gets in the way of the green
screening effect but today we're not
going to do that because I let my green
screen at a friend's place well which
friend it doesn't matter okay you don't
know her she's my one black friend
really yeah next to Tyrone Wow but this
one's getting your second black yeah
it's my second black house yeah well Tom
is not really a friend it's more of a
guy heard about OK on YouTube yeah
there's a big fan of this channel really
we need that anyway a cure for wellness
rather than that's trying to you know
come up with something clever to tell
you what the plot is about there's a
beautiful website out there called I am
DB oh man
it stands for incredible midgets big big
ambitious young executive is sent to
retrieve is company CEO permit idyllic
but idyllic Goodell ik the mysterious
Wellness Center at a remote location in
swish out but soon specs that visage and
the sheriff's treatment are not what
they seem this film is directed by Gore
Verbinski and written by the guy who
wrote The Lone Ranger and something that
I really picked up on when I was
watching this film Revolutionary Road
really has that vibe you know
yeah and snitch with the rock and yeah
Jon Bernthal you why they go alright you
can see why they got this right this is
an original concept than a lot of people
after after the film was done you know
kept saying that it harkens back to you
know old school kind of horror films
where it's like this movies like two and
a half hour long the big move it's a
tension builder it kind of builds a
little too much for me at times there's
a solid par like in the middle where I'm
like I want some things to start
actually happening yeah out of the way
upfront this movie looks and feels
amazing like it's terrific to behold and
there are points in the middle where I
feel like it's slow burning to the point
where
coasting more on its aesthetics and
actually moving along in an engaging
pace at a time like I felt like 15
minutes of this dome could have been
trimmed down probably yeah but that's
that's my primary John stop kicking the
tribe would you I'm sorry I'm super
hydrated
I'm trying that or thread my knees too
wide and encroach upon Ying what you got
all this when she sure left a little bit
because I don't really out of my brain
that's two out of frame I'm glad or
Verbinski did this some because yeah the
first film I ever saw is was the ring
and that was a great horror film I
always forget that too didn't see the
original ring you everyone says is
better but let's face it the ring was a
monumental film an American horror
cinema I was just so happy for him to be
doing another horror film again and this
film is really good it's great actually
it's surprisingly like it builds so much
to the point that when violence stuff
starts to happen it's not throughout but
it can get pretty violent when it's time
for the movie to either get violent or
to get like twisted and unsettling like
it really does not skimp on that so
there's a lot of like body horror a lot
of like unsettling sort of unnatural
caricature like characterizations and
stuff like it's ready
uncomfortable mouthing yes for so much
of it and there are things there are a
lot of things we're not going to spoil
here but there are a lot of things that
will make you cringe so long so this
film it's about this guy Dane DeHaan
it's about Dane DeHaan biopic yeah Dane
DeHaan is this young you know corporate
investor kind of dude who is being
threatened because he got he done some
illegal up in the books and he's Mindy
special to coat me over Swiss Alps to go
retrieve a man who can sign some
documents yeah basically the CEO of the
company has gone AWOL he's holed up at
this Wellness Center and they need him
to sign off on the hard right thing
otherwise everyone's in deep [ __ ] and
this some I remind you of films like The
Shining or shutter island' a little bit
so when they go to the Swiss Alps and
they go to this location of this
Wellness Center it's an instantly creepy
yeah it has its own vibe and it is a
very sort of pretty but also just dark
seeming oh yeah everyone seems kind of
a little bit like their brains might be
being tampered with
ya can't tell if it's manipulation are
they doing surgery on their brains and
God I'm going to be a little control as
everyone kind of has a freaky
personality over at this Wellness Center
Dane DeHaan gets in an accident that
looks like it could be an accident but
had it thrown into the Wellness Center
he has to go through treatment as he's
going through recovery for his broken
leg and the main thing about this
Wellness Center that they have a thing
they thrive on is their water they have
this pure natural water that could heal
the body yeah they have this crazy
aquifer like hot spring thing with this
yeah
specially enriched water that is sort of
the secret to everything but Dane DeHaan
getting worse he's getting worse and he
notices the people around him kind of
our - everyone's getting worse Dane
DeHaan being a [ __ ] American it has
to be like I don't like the way things
were going I'm gonna kick my foot in the
door and try to figure out what's really
going on to get this [ __ ] myself
now when real investigation of all the
shady saw on the trailer of them of him
like oh what's going on here I got
figure it out it doesn't happen till
like an hour into the film a lot of it
is building up you're getting to know
the characters you get to know jason
isaacs character there's Cara's called
bull more or boomer bull Melbourne and
it's is he's basically the guy who runs
the Institute the Institute is called
the volar Institute so he's like the
head doctor and there's other patients
that for the main patients they get to
know who's keep everyone keeps saying
this very special patient or me agaves a
girl named Hannah
at first she looks like she's like 15 16
I couldn't talk and it just seemed like
Dane Thomas kind of into her yeah a
little bit that's not really important
to the movie they have some kind of
connection because she says it at one
point in actually a really nice moment
she says like he's the only even vaguely
young person here so I think they just
relate on that quality they're both a
little bit outsider in this but it
sounds like she was kind of born there
like they have this backstory with her
where she experienced a lot of trauma
and then she was brought to the Wellness
Center but maybe it's not she's been
practically raised their whole life yeah
so and jason isaacs character takes a
very strong liking to her so there's a
lot of mystery building here and we
don't want to do a spoiler review
because what we just told you is a lot
of what you wouldn't
in the first hour of the film but here's
what we can tell you this home delivers
on being eerie it delivers on being
creepy yeah everything you and there's
some great great visual that are
sometimes scary at times just beautiful
to look at John said at first he
wouldn't have minded seen this film on
IMAX and I agree with that like honestly
I felt kind of like I was watching an
IMAX movie part of the way through and
some of that's just into the opening
scene yeah oh definitely like what a
holding isn't Sofia the building denied
that train shot within your image from
the trailer like you know everything
feels huge in this movie that's
something that's really cool to me and I
think people will generally appreciate
it like they really sunk a lot of effort
into this movie the sets and the
locations I guess you know the different
rooms and the way the world grows based
on that like it is very beautiful to
look at signs are incredible the
atmosphere of the character in and of
itself and there's a lot of mystery
going on it seems like this Wellness
Center is like up it like above a
village or some yes it's yes it's just
above this really small kind of modern
gaming village a small town this story
of the history of the Wellness Center
some people have this interpretation
other people have this interpretation so
as the movie continues er you're
figuring out like what's the real story
behind the Wellness Center and what's
the story beyond what they're doing now
so you're figuring out the past of how
it came to be and what what makes it so
important and why it's also [ __ ]
terrifying
yeah and then you're also learning what
the hell is really going on this is the
kind of film that you've got to give it
some time after an hour I started
thinking is this so me going to start
delivering yeah um is it so we're going
to start going somewhere where it's
thrilling or scary or creepy give it
some time you will leave with a very
unsettled feeling
yeah and part of me wonders is like if I
go back and see this again sometime you
know cuz I cryed it better yeah and the
pace might improve because there are
movies for whom that works when you you
know what to expect you're not looking
as hard in every direction to be like
come on give me yeah it might improve
that way on the second time around as
far makes the length of this film as
part what makes it brilliant normally a
story like this would be like our a half
hour and 40 minutes or something this
story is two and a half hours long so
they really take
they're time to put you into this world
and experience the life of what it's
like to be a patient here that's
something I appreciate about it it's a
wallet Merlot's down the plot a little
bit because you're spending so much time
learning what it's like to be a sin
actual patient here it builds it even
more and makes everything make more
sense for the ones who just won't go
against the doctors here and all that
stuff yeah the people who are so
brainwashed by the idea or whatever or
are they exactly
is Dane DeHaan crazy and there's some
violence in here that I have not seen in
other movies like violence where yeah
they don't violence set pieces like that
in other films but the way it's captured
like a lot of people are talking about
this dentist scene oh boy and they don't
give away how they do it but they just
let the camera roll and you to me what's
going on yeah and that's yeah that's
that's the thing there are lots of
things in this movie that make me kind
of surprised in a happy way but again
like a big scope wide release yeah movie
is getting the Liberty to do so these
things because people are gotta be
talking about a few of these things
because it's so the film feels big it
feels expensive so when you get certain
scenes of violence like one that
involves a two going down a guy's throat
the way they show it the way they do it
is they make this is serving and kind of
impressive
yeah it looks so good that you could ice
in your chair and then you're you have
to pay respect to that like that's
effective body Horrors body out it makes
you feel it don't mind the length too
much because even though we are we start
off this route kind of talking about the
initial complaint there's like a part in
the middle where you're like to start
giving us some answers that's part of
what makes the film effective is because
it's a mystery and you want answers
these are like biting for some acid and
design to honk air there's been there a
longer than we've been in the theater
yeah so over there with him going we
want to know the truth of what's going
on yeah like one big reveal all of a
sudden it slowly uncovers over time well
yeah because he's got a you know observe
behaviors and look for little clues and
so do we
so you know like that deliberate pacing
I think isn't alright yeah I got upset
about you know the moments in the middle
rows like no come on pick it up it's
beautifully shot it's wonderfully the
serving it's eerie
the music's good music is great the
pieces are really good now without
spoiling anything the finale in the
movies like this a problem tend to come
down to the finale I feel I can simply
imagine going on rotten tomatoes and
seeing a bunch of capitals where they're
talking about kind of loses its way in
the finale is a little too crazy no
perfect it gets a little far-fetched in
this finale we won't give it away but it
becomes like I didn't really see a tone
or style like this coming but yeah I can
get on board with it for now that's the
only that's something that makes me want
to see this again because I still don't
know if I like the movie as a whole
based on that ending or not yeah and
it's I guess it's cool because it's it's
stuck with me as a film experience like
I'm glad I saw it and I'm glad it exists
I don't know yet if I like the ending
it's one of the biggest questions of
this film what is Jason Isaacs deal what
who the [ __ ] is this guy what is he
doing is he good is he bad I mean for
the most part the whole film was like
good saying he's probably bad work any
more than three times you're like well
maybe Dane DeHaan just a little nuts you
know well and the movie does I think a
pretty good job of showing that line cuz
any movie like this has to it like is
our protagonist crazy or is something
sinister actually happening here I
thought Jason Isaacs did again what's
giving nothing away I thought he played
it you know in a real good sort of
balanced way where I a lot of the time
couldn't tell which way there yeah
because there's a lot of reveals that
are happening that towards the last like
half hour of this film Lots finally
being uncovered one aspect there's many
aspects of one of the aspects it was the
one aspect where I was like having
issues with I don't know about this
would have to do with finally figuring
out the truth about who Jason Isaacs is
and that's all all things sudden I guess
like in a nutshell about this movie it's
ultimately the difference to me between
being you know is this movie really
great or is it mostly pretty great you
know well Jon that leads us to our
rating system oh boy what's the ring
since I think I'll go with a good - very
good is there a middle ground between
those two yeah I probably go very good
at taking down a notch there's some
great stuff in it there's some excellent
and/or really great awesome stuff in it
and
there's stuff that I really love about
it as a whole piece I think it's
probably like very good maybe good if
I'm feeling kind of harder on it today
but right now I feel like a second real
win would earn a great rating I hope so
yeah yeah because like there are a
couple things that have stuck in my craw
that I really want to see if those iron
out because there are things again going
back to not the ending like the finale
per se not like the big finale thing
that everyone's going to be talking
about which is like the note the movie
actually ends on I think is cool you
know like the actual choice the movie
makes about its main character at the
end I think is a cool thing the true
test of time with this movie is going to
be I think on the second viewing but I'm
really glad we got a film like this
because I love dis vibe and the rating
system means everything that's all we
ever came up with the most brilliant
rating system out there and then that
was all very clear about how we rated it
yeah
so there's many options in the rating
students very really subscribe to the
real rejects subscribe John is reading
to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram as a
social media manager of bloom house and
the real rejects and shout out to Gore
Verbinski's wife what yeah I don't know
if he's married
I'm find out I'm out IMDB trivia already
on IMDB I'm doing it for late in Burbank
Clayton
woo sigue sigue nothing about it I'm not
gonna about googling for bits Gore
Verbinski on ghoulia Clayton Verbinski
now that's a woman that is a gal it's a
woman being gay that's disappointing
I just hope they're happiest that's the
truth I want to liked him more if he was
gay
it'd be cool but you know what like the
witch house keys are gay lovers right
that's the truth exactly as it happened
lesbian lovers yeah all of it celebrity
trivia celebrity trivia Schmo down